- [Interviewer] All right, Evelyn,
- [Evelyn] Yes?
- [Interviewer] Evelyn,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Evelyn] I'm from a river town called
Richland, Washington.
- [Interviewer] Is that near Seattle?
- It's downwind from Seattle,
near Hanford, Washington,
where metal cars and
refrigerators are made.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood,
you had both your parents?
- Yes, I did.
I had an elderly father
and a brunette mother.
- [Interviewer] How, how
was, how was your childhood?
- It was fine, lots of running
and early dance lessons
with the Russian masters.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- I was an early listener.
I would come in at about
two o'clock in the afternoon
not wanting to be in sweated
clothes or slip on the desk.
And I would put my feet
up on the desk,
and not look around.
And, the first word was Paris Review.
And we were able to travel
the ski lodges that summer,
and see the mountains
as they were iced up.
And we just wore short sleeve t-shirts
and our exposure and teenage years,
and went to the desert after that
for some nude running, and
found myself near a shop.
Returned home with a
dress and found myself
in a long bugety dress and
hung it out on the line.
And the woman appeared,
and she grew to be my sister, Jean.
And she taught me sewing,
It was from a black enamel
S inger sewing machine,
and it kept the house cool.
And we poured fudge that
Christmas and my brother appeared.
And he's now a minister at
Glide Memorial hospital.
- [Interviewer] So your
childhood sounds pretty good.
- Yeah, not a lot of time with my parents,
as I had to make my own
money for my future college.
I had a set on my heart as a
youngster to remain with books.
even if my mother and
father went to the parks
or accident or injury.
And my elder sister took me
into her home for three years.
As I watched her growing
through her early marriage.
Now she's been married
up for past 55 years.
- [Interviewer] How old are you Evelyn?
- I'm 61.
- [Interviewer] Have you been married?
- No I haven't.
- [Interviewer] You have children.
- Yes, I do. I have 2.
- [Interviewer] And did you raise them?
- Yes. Yes I did, along with my sisters.
And my three brothers also have children,
and he played and they
sorted the toys out.
- [Interviewer] So today you're
living in the Tenderloin,
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] San Francisco.
- [Interviewer] How long
have you been living here?
- Since the year 2000, stopping
in front of the pop shop
and getting cherry Cola.
♪ Cherry cola, ch-ch-ch-ch-Cola. ♪
Yeah and that brought the train to stop,
as it nearly went off the road.
And I was able to hang
from the dung sport.
Those old mule lines and clip those.
- [Interviewer] Are you
living on the streets now?
- with a squiggle straw.
Yeah, mostly to keep the roof up, as I'm a weightlifter
in my New York years running
track and shooting baskets.
And then that brought me home
to my father's old globe head.
And he didn't take me in,
He told me the sky is falling,
and I went in the back,
and found the typewriter.
He took electrical engineering
from about the year 1919.
and I was able to write a full screenplay,
called The Sky is Blue.
And took it to New York and deposited it
in the glove in the bin,
the Franklin mint.
And it came up as diamond earrings,
and elevator.
And I was in that elevator
rising to NBC studios
where I met Donald Trump.
- [Interviewer] Do you
live in a tent today?
- I'd been in two tents,
did not enjoy the "squoshen" conditions.
- [Interviewer] So you're
basically just living
on the street now without a tent.
- Yeah. There's a little
zipper job there,
and those singer black hat.
- [Interviewer] What
do you do for a living?
- The tent got too hot.
So I said, Keith Sweat,
and did like the black guys
do and paddled out on my own.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
rough things happen to you
here on the streets?
- Rough things, no.
The worst I've had, is a cigarette burn
to my inner thigh, and that was looking
at the boys' hand who
kept a pipe in his hands
hearing arrest from citizen officers.
They can be dressed in day clothes, or
as you'll find pizza dinner
followed by root beer and Coke.
And that will make an officer,
if you've in need of a parent,
but if you have your parents,
then they can speak to them for you
if you're dragged
through the court system.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn, do
you use any of the drugs
that are on the street?
- I used marijuana from a thing
like McDonald's wrappers.
Those are less, you can leave
the chunk of beef in there
and you'll later find
your marijuana cigarette.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever,
you ever been in a mental health facility
or anything?
- Yes, I went voluntarily,
to get the temperature of my outdoor body.
And was able to walk out with black shoes
and take a bus ride to a Meineke shop,
where I saw the Japanese hostesses,
with there Sherbet hair
that is running sweat.
As their toddlers were
curbed to the street
and netted behind their backs,
probably nauseous and overheated.
Maybe an infant mortality.
And I went back out to the hospital,
to get thermometers and
band-aids and found them just
outside the door and was
lucky to get away again.
Cause mental institutions
are mostly MC Hammer
or old cereal scoops,
those little Cheerios.
Those will make a nurse in a hurry.
And that's on the floor.
There'll just be a double bed.
- [Interviewer] Does your
family know that you're done?
Does your family know
that you're living here
on the streets?
- Oh yes.
I wrote them for about 12 years,
an easy dozen,
pieces of paper were rolled up
and made into smoking papers.
Which I deposited into a,
a rake for the parks.
And that made my uncle come up
from Milwaukee, an old beer drinking town.
Where the Buffalo would
come to the back door
and Grace, the nephew of the bartender.
And he'll look like a
grateful dead member,
with their guitar strung around the necks
and sweating up in the bugs,
coming from the laces of the, the cords.
Those are all keys that had been
strewn around the California pool.
- [Interviewer] Evelyn, how do you?
- [Evelyn] How do I spell my name?
- [Interviewer] No. How do you,
how do you support yourself?
How do you make money?
- [Evelyn] From check disbursement
I have,
no Florida transportation in me.
I whizzed by there, and was
able to see New York again,
just by missing Florida.
Then got and education in banking,
meaning bees and golf
nothing or throwing a scarf
around your neck to hide
your last whereabouts.
And people weren't able to follow me,
as I picked up pennies and toots,
that together made a quarter for those
and a Mountain Dew drink made a dollar
as it has to be warm, cool, hot.
Then the marijuana will make you,
So I don't over smoke on them,
that'll burn up green money.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have any friends, Evelyn?
- [Evelyn] I have five friends.
My son is my body guard
now, as he grew stronger
through free eats or depositing
your nice verbal messages
like good morning, have a nice day.
See you later, alligator.
And that'll make steps or an elevator.
And my sister, I think, went to Florida
and was able to photograph the alligators
climbing out of the swamps.
And that made the milkshakes
come up and I missed those.
So my face then enlarged, and
I was able to be photographed
with my screenplay and Donald Trump.
Then my screenplay just turned
into rolling paper and cigarettes.
But at one time, it was a Sony jewel,
making a marquee
as I held it up for a taxi driver.
And he lists me off to the early Bronx
or where the cab stops.
Preferring chocolate is
payment in the early years.
Now he accepts cash, but riding around,
and that black interior will
sure make the ghetto spring up.
And those boys are just
paid in milk and cereal.
- [Interviewer] All right, Evelyn.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- [Evelyn] Okay Albert.
- [Interviewer] And good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- [Evelyn] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Thank you
so much for your time.
- [Evelyn] Okay.
- [Interviewer] Did you call me Elmer?
- Albert
- [Interviewer] Albert? Oh.
- Yeah.
(Evelyn laughs)
- [Interviewer] You're very cute.
- Oh, thank you.